welcome to this video I'm playing Alex
from Germany and we have a capricorn
okay the g6 line yeah with okay not sure
that I know this one yeah but it's
probably nothing that can be directly
refuted how could I maybe maybe i can i
can play for quick quick age 5 yes but
this is this weakening this is weakening
the dark squares are a potential issue
should I play five and probably probably
assured and now I can also retreat to e3
yeah and Bishop d3 anthesis this could
be dangerous
leading to various attacking ideas
that's a six is a very slow move okay
yeah well okay Bishop g6 he will play
rook gaem this is the defense takes on
f7 king of 1703 check yeah well this is
this is some attack it's not it's not
ridiculous so let's do that let's do
that itself it's the only really um yeah
the the only really fitting move to what
I played before can you take I just
wondered if he can take here yeah
takes here tween a three check that's
not not really really working if I am
play Bishop takes it's also night xt5
at-6 it's not not out of the question
but 95 you can take III as well ok let's
continue yeah that the danger of this
type of game oasis that well I'm not
sure about the objective merit of this
but why does attacking maybe white is in
excellent shape but it took me a lots of
time to play those moves and black is
just playing whatever to continue turn
well now drop takes rook GH I can take a
playbook f4 and I'm threatening to take
on f7 now anyway this might be really
good for me
yeah and he's catching up a bit on the
clock that's that's a that's reassuring
takes Queen takes King of a Droog f4 was
very easy come on give me a break my
writing is really low I really need to
go back above 2,300 below 2,200 feels
like I'm in a really bad shape well I'm
not in good shape this is clear just by
the games but I really don't kept my
rating above 23 at the moment I just
keep on losing silly games and yeah well
you haven't seen the the warm-up games
these days I even it worse when I start
the first game of a session ends usually
just just a big punishment okay this is
basically saying okay you're right you
could you could sacrifice yeah oh I come
on check keep it simple and Queen g7 at
the end check Luke h7 look f 8 i'm
getting a getting the material back the
rook is basically trapped now that's no
way to save it
Luke age seven who gave a check bishop
of a teenage seven minutes just check
just a couple of extra pawns and an
overwhelming position Queen age 5 and so
on yeah even have a couple of pawns this
is check this is comfortable okay let's
get the points rolling
95 ET rook takes attacking the green and
attacking the bishop almost it's almost
working okay but it's not necessary
actor to do such fancy stuff just
getting the night to d4 should should be
nice nice enough
we should be six I just go see three
look the ATF knight c6 or queen d 896 so
okay check check not quite sure why the
game is continuing maybe he has watched
my recent games okay black resigned yeah
it maybe it was just just a good game
but that tend to be skeptical at the
moment I overlooked too many things ok
and that's let's check let's check
around around here if I've he returned
to seven push it back yeah I expected c5
see if I yeah I know I took let's see
what the computer is giving yeah its
first computer evil is so excellent for
black so it was not really working and
this is the computer line at Dave 94 the
compounds to play rock g ade yeah well I
was thinking that check the shack is
some compensation but the computers is
it's not impressed yeah Queen age five
this Queen yet with the defense
probably yeah the problem is that Miami
center is a bit shaky hmm yeah that's
not good the way it was Plato probably
it was it was good yeah this is just
winning now and check exactly with this
line yeah okay this was this was fine
though all right yeah well I hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching